君たちお肌に悩んだことありますか
あるはい僕も某中学校の時はニキビに悩んでもういやもブツブツで本当に中学時代は
もうに君にしかなやんてなかったようなもんだったんですけどそこのお肌に悩むきび
立つ
お前等をが何何が効くかは誰か
そう化粧品でも
なんか塗るのってもない何が大事かというと
僕にもわかりません豆乳
豆乳ってお前等知ってるかな君たち知らないでしょうね
豆乳って何も大豆から豆から作られてるんですけど
ビタミン b 1やビタミン b 2が含まれていますでそれにはへと皮膚や粘膜を
健康にして肌荒れを予防したり疲れにくくなる効果があります
ナットえっ
納豆のほうが効果あるのそういうのはどうでもいいんですよとりあえず投入は体にいっ
てことはもう間違いないんだよねこの bc の高い男子にはね
豆乳的なねそういうドリンクで音が出せないんですよ
なので超じゃあ僕が僕が目に入った豆乳全種ないよちょっとお店から買ってきたんで
今日は購入全種類ませんでね地図を最強のね
美容とリンク方で作ってね飲んでね
技術に自慢する動画を取ろうと思います石膏種類あるぜ
ブーツチョコ落下を至急なきゃなんねーんだよって今来てるッ
調整もう雑色にとらわれているこの何項
なにこの角にはまったこの企画内の味っていうものに僕はもう飽き飽きしてるんで
パスタポットって書いてあるんですけどまあとりあえず
投入全部2年で飲んで地上最強の日の手術の味をね
今日はね僕がもう体感しようと思います
じゃ入れますん
パスと杖
普通のんだ絶対はしてちょっと何味になると思いますか
あの絶対2時なんだらおいしいもう
前買った
寝返るいねえウールアームふううううううああもう入れギロがやないのだ
いい
say
できればで六男性は入れたくなかったのだからおいしくないもん
これなんかじっとかというより量の問題なよし
ああああああああ
母
なんかコンクリートみたいな人ですね何安になるんだろう
全然予想つかんしゅこれこれないかな
pastor いるなんだよは web ライターやっぱりダメでしょ
ほらねっと混ぜたいんだよねー
うん
という
仏教きょん
じゃあこのイソフラボンの刷毛もうね
今から飲もうと思います
何味だと思いますがちなみにん
このコンクリートの色からしてねボックは
笹にやとかそこらへん価格
他の日ちょっと飲んでみたよ
ちょっとさせてみますじゃあいただきます
満足はないと思う
ん
何さ
何
わがまま
美味しくはないはからなんだろうこれちょっと待っていっ
なんかねえ
ガムの味がします
ん
4日
あああああ
ん
うん
ああああああああ
ブーブー音
ん
ううううううん2